نعم وسيله الكثير من التطورات في الميدان
في قطاع غزه كاملا كما نشاهده على هذه
الخريطه هنا من شماله وحتى جنوبه اللون
الاصفر هو لحركه المناورات
الاسرائيليه نشاهدها وقد كانت قد تغيرت
خلال الايام الاخيره خاصه في كل من شمال
قطاع غزه هنا اضافه الى وسط القطاع في هذه
المناطق الان اللون الاصفر كما ذكرنا هو
لحركه المناورات الاسرائيليه اللون الازرق
هنا هو للمنطقه العسكريه المغلقه حول غلاف
غزه كنا سمعنا منذ قليل لمراسلنا دياس
كرام بانه تم استهداف المقاومه ما زالت
تملك القوه الصاروخيه لاستهداف ديروت
اضافه الى مناطق مختلفه في قطاع غزه رغم
مرور نحو 115 يوما على العمليات العسكريه
الان هذا سيقودنا الى شمال قطاع غزه
المقاومه كانت قد ذكرت بانها تمكنت من
الاستيلاء على طائرات درون هنا في بيت
لاهيه اضافه الى ان ال ما تزال هناك في
المرحله الثالثه من الحرب في قطاع في شمال
قطاع غزه هنا في هذه
النقطه سنلاحظ بان القوات قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما تزال بدات تغير نوعا من
التكتيكات وباستخدام الطيران القصف هنا
باتجاه الشيخ رضوان اضافه الى مناطق
بالقرب من الرمال الجنوبي محاوله للتركيز
باستخدام الطيران مقارنه بالعمليات البريه
الت التي تجري فيها المناورات في المناطق
ذات اللون الاصفر لكن القصف يكون في
المناطق الخاليه تقريبا من اللون الاصفر
يعني كنمط للعمليات التي تحدث في شمال
قطاع غزه اما في الوسط ايضا هناك كان
تغييرات التغييرات في اللون الاصفر
والمناورات هي كانت على محور شارع صلاح
الدين هذا هو محور شارعع شارع صلاح الدين
خلال الايام الست الاخيره كانت القوات
الاسرائيليه تقوم بالتوغل
والعوده لكن هذا التوغل توغل وظهور
الاليات في هذه المنطقه اختفى جزئيا خلال
الايام السته الاخيره لكن ايضا مره اخرى
قصف بالطيران في مخيم النصيرات بالتالي
سنشاهد هذا النمط بين عمليات البريه
وجودها في هذه المناطق ارتكاز من الشرق
دفع باتجاه الجنوب لكن قصف الطيران يكون
في مناطق خاليه تقريبا من اللون الاصفر
وذلك في نوع ما بين العمليات العسكريه
الجويه والعمليات العسكريه
البريه الاستهداف هنا في مناطق لا تكون
فيها متواجده القوات البريه ب كثافه
بطبيعه الحال مركز استقل العمليات هو في
خان يونس كما كنا نشاهد الان كان
هناك مقاطع فيديو بثتها كتائب القسام كان
هناك استهدافات لدبابات ميركافا
لكن مركز تقال العمليات هو في غرب خان
يونس من هذه النقطه هنا محاولات الدفع
باتجاه مستشفى الامل ايضا من جنوب خان
يونس و شاهدنا استهدافات للمقاومه في هذه
النقاط هنا
ا كان هناك ايضا استهدافات من مسافه قريبه
باستخدام قذائف الياسين وربما تقل حتى عن
بضع عشرات من الامتار وهي المسافه اللازمه
لتفعيل نظام تروفي ان كان موجودا طبعا هذه
كانت هي ابرز العمليات العسكريه بالنسبه
لنا لهذا اليوم وسيكون هناك المزيد من
التفاصيل طبعا وبطبيعه الحال لاحقا خلال
الساعات المقبله الان